son sólo algunas de las 120.000 personas
temporalmente evacuadas de sus casas en
la provincia china de shanxi a causa del
temporal de los últimos días los
voluntarios se entregaron productos
básicos a los afectados
charly y hemos hecho todo lo posible
para desplegar todo tipo de asistencia
de emergencia incluyendo equipamientos
vehículos y personal voluntario de
distintas localidades para participar en
los esfuerzos de rescate
este fin de semana el río que pasa por
esta ciudad alcanzó el máximo caudal de
los últimos 40 años china tiene un plan
de emergencia de cuatro niveles para
controlar las inundaciones el nivel más
bajo ha sido decretado en sants y en la
septentrional provincia china millones
de personas se han visto afectadas por
las constantes lluvias torrenciales que
empezaron la semana pasada el temporal
ha destruido más de 17.000 casas y ha
dañado cerca de 190.000 hectáreas de
cultivos los equipos de socorro y de
rescate han empezado a actuar a pesar de
que las persistentes precipitaciones
dificultaron su trabajo
las autoridades provinciales han
destinado casi 8 millones de dólares a
las tareas de emergencia la crisis
actual llega a apenas tres meses después
de que las lluvias torrenciales y las
inundaciones en la provincia de henán
causarán más de 300 muertes